how are you Landon I'm great how about
you guys I'm hanging in there thanks
very much so give me the sense
give me the sense of of what that locker
rooms like right now the the sky seems
to be falling on local sports talk radio
how about that locker room Landon
nobody's written bound up one finger so
V stay together stay tight as the
Brotherhood in it
okay so the the the sense in that locker
room that it's still tight what do you
make of the argument in town that Eli
Manning that the Giants stuck with him
too long that they should have drafted
his replacement how does that land in
your locker room Landon Collins um we
believe in Eli guys that's how
quarterback I thought got it so we
looking forward to have a leader to the
for the promise month yeah I thought God
and say Quan Barkley how's he fit in
there he's doing good I mean honestly I
mean he's got our run game gone a little
bit and doing some amazing things is
definitely when he's testing a bother
back though and I'm getting some first
downs but he's done a great job okay so
what do you say to the Giants fan base
that's panicking right now don't jump to
conclusions a bad start but some teams
that win dad's best finish strong so a
word okay
and when it all comes down to this
weekend against Carolina
I know it's first blush it's still a
Tuesday right now what challenges does
that pose to you Landon run to the ball
play hard like it always has been done
and try to get out the ball back as much
as we can for our quarterback be the
offensive door so what type of business
decision is that when you see number one
coming at you these slides stay off of
them but is running in chopper 2 so that
is how they come up I mean I think I'm
out with that one no I understand what
you mean by that but I guess the
business decision I guess would be
making is that he's so big coming
at you and you're the safety coming
downhill what that yeah what challenge
that proposes I think I mean I've been
in I beg of people think I'm so I think
I could do very well enough okay
what's the conversation landing columns
been in your locker about the roughing
the passer penalties that seems to have
been changed over this past week of the
way they called it through the first
three weeks of the season honestly don't
play we don't play our em don't play
football
we're not going to change any way any
kind of you might want to change their
would be played because of the rules I
mean stuff happens that happens I mean
it's on it is really on arrest
discretion if you hit somebody land for
the on top of a quarterback or something
like that so if you're gonna continue
playing football landing Collins are the
Giants here on the Rich Eisen show you
your comment prior to the game against
Dallas certainly caught my eye and ears
about putting the hands the ball in the
hands of deck and that was the way that
you could beat the Dallas Cowboys does
that is that still your philosophy
playing Dallas after that game Landon
playing after day game yeah honestly I
mean I mean it's not to the fact he
would take it out it out of out of out
of context and I say putting that kinda
got a better time to say I'm like he
wants him to pass the ball put him in
throw it down in all situations but I
mean that's how y'all want to put it
that's how you want to put it no I
but folks did take it to mean that you
did not feel that he was a threat to the
winning lost column on that night
no it wasn't he wasn't worried too much
about that was the fact that how we how
we want the game to play out we want the
Minturn in long situation
Lena Collins here on the Rich Eisen show
Odell Beckham has yet to catch a
touchdown passes that's something the
locker room is aware of I know about
when we score and we got young sure okay
will to have a snap in the fourth
quarter this year Landon Collins in
Alabama that's a good question honestly
uh I got two is doing an amazing job
over there and leading the tide and a
great way well he has a full quarter
game is never not a thought in my mind
it might happen how is it was the
champion
you know you get teams get more time to
study one another um maybe maybe it's a
slim maybe though I've never seen
anything like it I know it we're still
early in the college football season too
but he may be the first Heisman Trophy
quarterback candidate to have the
second-most snaps on his team it's
unbelievable all right so what's the
angle what's the craziest or or angriest
Nick Saban ever got with you Landon I
didn't I think you just picking on me
but I didn't do who uh kick back on punt
team I was a leveling on a front and
then kick back correctly and uh you kind
of got only very very tough I mean like
you take every part of the game very
seriously and that's what I expect some
women that's what he did you know kind
of ripped me a new one
so I guess take a number on that front I
mean how did he get you ready for the
NFL
honestly I'm he's a great coach he
statistics he plays but great I mean
that place but he coaches great ball I
mean he's very in tones it was his
players and with anything how to teach
them as men and young athlete okay what
are you doing for uh what are you doing
for Dairy Queen sir what's going on with
them and so this past weekend
I went to high school local high school
in New Jersey and I saw some new Dairy
Queen from their farm interested first
time during the fall menu and handouts
and blizzards there's some awesome stuff
you got to taste out for the new fall
menu and it was awesome job and we also
gave about the nation but 2500 to school
for their equipment but a football team
okay well congratulations on that good
good job out of you doing stuff in the
community like that and let's let's chat
down a line with you and the Giants okay
Landon let's not let's not let's not go
this long the night in it the next time
all right that's a Landon Collins giant
safety the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience